this video is brought to you by
expressvpn and Shopify people more on
them after the
reaction ho ho ho Merry Christmas ladies
and gentlemen it is time for what if
season 2 episode thrust today COI how
are you feeling festive how you feeling
Greg good how's that peanut butter bar
delicious needed it took a big old you
started the intro realiz you're reading
right now my bad anyway guys be sure to
leave a like a Holly Jolly like how's
your Christmas going leave your thoughts
Down Below in the comments on xmus
what'd you get was a good present you
got I want to know tell me your best
xmus present you're X-Men tell me tell
us tell all everybody uh subscribe and
click the notification Bell cuz we are
powering through these right now and
also uh thank you to prepper for helping
us edit down these highlights you don't
get to have Christmas and full length re
action watch we syn with your own copy
of what if that is available for super
sexy rejects thank you all have been
joining us at our patreon page uh
becoming super sexy rejects that's what
you are there and John and I cover
several things exclusively with
highlights and wash Longs included I
covered everything Co I just realized
it's Christmas Eve and they're watching
this but maybe they watched it late
merry Christmas tomorrow L people
celebrate on Christmas who knows who
knows I mean hi let's do it we'll see
you
soon isn't this nice it is no better
time of year let me tell you one of my
my favorite Yu tide stories okay it was
the night before Christmas and all
through the tower The Avengers were
fighting a brand new
superpower stockings were hung by the
chimney well not anymore it's cool see
IR debuting
[Music]
yes uh right you're probably wondering
who this guy is yes perhaps I should
start a bit further
back who's almost Hulk here it looks
like Drax Hulk I'm curious Hulk axe I do
love that it's Downey I mean that it's
Iron Man cuz Iron Man 3 is a Christmas
story I love uh I'm curious who it's
going to
be it's more than wait Mark Mark uh no
it was Scarlet him I'm gonna go happy
Hogan yeah it's a happy Hogan episode is
it yeah but I'm gonna hulkus
Hogan oh that's going to be my bet cuz
Iron Man oh
let's take it was only 2 hours prior and
the tower was not yet on
fire left to the no too much left stop
stop Yes do we find out who bought
Avengers Mansion go give you where's the
Showmanship where are the K buns Darcy
you want to get college credit for this
listen to me ah okay fine fine t to the
four Puffin too wait why am I a puffin
and a second Puffin at that who's the
first Puffin Bernard accounting okay
that just
hurts director Hill you're looking quite
she's uh festive now that Jarvis has
been shut down for maintenance oh I want
to talk to you about that I love how
happy Hogan looks Slimmer they drew him
that way yeah one request puka playlist
that one Mariah Carey song on Loop Bingo
all I want for Christmas is you don't
don't you do it Dar all a good Justin
Hamber Sam Rockwell's back I've wanted
him back so much or maybe this is the
story of of how Justin Hammer Stole
Christmas
yes blw up the Stark Expo he found
himself on the naughty
list time to reflect time
to ponder his future cook up a plan
Justin Hammer had a little too much
time oh it's a Die Hard Die Hard Sam
Rockwell yes
Alan Rickman
perfect beautiful people people listen
up you stay calm you stay quiet and I
guarantee that you'll be home for the
holidays damn Hammer buffed
up also his notes I wanted a Red Rider
BB gun more than anything in the world I
begged my parents I beged Santa for it
accidentally got my stuck on a telephone
pole isn't that a a classic
movie but I didn't get the BB gun that
Christmas do you know why shoot your eye
out shoot your eye out and if you want
something you got to take it Amen
brother I mean yeah yeah capitalism
capitalism keeps things going oh he
unplugged Jarvis for 5 minutes the whole
building
collapses so he's taking over Jarvis
that's amazing relax reprogramming
command protocols setting new targets
all on site staff sounds good to me
what ha red eyes symbolism of evil
they're bad guys now and
[Music]
christmy so Darcy's gonna have to stve
the day and happy Hogan's gonna be
trapped inside as mlan he's Bruce Willis
yeah yeah Behind These doors is a gamma
radiated antigen serum Hulk blood your
prediction is right I think it is
correct I think and he becomes Hulk
Hogan
oh Tony's been messing around with
Banner's blood seeing if he can make him
the Hulk without the uh Anchor
management issues was he successful uh
you know it's a
process oh oh that's not good okay okay
go through the shaft there time for me
to go and sit on Tony's Throne I'm not
going to flush if you get my drift oh
he's going to [__] on Tony's Throne come
on it's Christmas I think I have a way
in good cuz I've got
[Music]
Hammer ring the Jingle
Bells throw a holiday party it'll be fun
Tony soon
said he's doing it he's doing the Die
Hard he's quoting the die
hards and he's doing the
dance just like his Charlie's Angels
villain yes all the best Sam Rockwell
characters dance Confessions of a
dangerous mind whoa the day that you
face off against Tony Stark's greatest
adversary greatest adversary what are
you a wealth
tax your Technique is all more strength
in back less arms more hips you think
Hammer would have some type of
technology that would break through this
glass at least something better than a
hammer
ah
Hammer I love it Christmas Hulk blood
okay just we think little fire find the
Hulk
no did you hear
that
oh got it good hands happy Hogan do you
want to know what the most important
thing I learned in lock up is cheating
is for
winners I could learn a thing or two
from Hammer yeah got to do
it [__] be a shadow be a loose Shadow
I've mastered the art of
invisibility come on what's a guy got to
do to find epidural a banner blood Hulk
huh confetti Arrow oh come on
Tony it's for Hawkeyes prepping all
right I should definitely be getting
Hazard paid for
this that's how it happened why did you
do
[Laughter]
that oh that's not
good yeah you're going to need it man oh
yeah the things you learn working for a
mad over caffeinated scientist
incoming what is that going to I hope
you knew what that was matter with
you just one leg oh you got a big box of
coal coming your way missy cuffer I'm
sick of this chick roasting my
chestnuts I love when these villains in
Christmas movies know how to just make
all the Christmas punts they just know
the layers we want I love they probably
told Sam Rockway to come back as Hans
scruber and he's like yes let me make
puns okay yes there's no in there is no
in team
what your first person that calls
Natasha not a great time I'm being held
at gunpo by a former Hydra agent with 17
kills 18 kills you want me to get you
help oh no I've got
this perfect timing happy can you tell
Timmy here that a replica cap Shield is
nothing but a patriotic frisbee
emergency whoa trouble here too soccer
mom's cornering got to go quality sound
alike he does sound alike really good
work just give it a toy no come on just
let just let her have it the wife says
bring home this toy or don't come home
at all Dam it just let let her have
it
God oh yeah start pouring the Shirley
temples big guy got your cherries
Sparrow one this is perin
to it's funny how he's like slowly
morphing puffing poo Jarvis has a main
frame in the sub basement if we bring
Jarvis back online then we could take
control of the building and everything
inside of it are you asking me to be
Reginald Bel Johnson Reginal Bel Johnson
that's what you remember from the
movie why wouldn't that was such a good
[Music]
joke the only way out is
out Ah that's neat
die
[Music]
holy
oh
no Hulk
Hogan this way every wall he smashes
through he evolves a little bit
more looks more like Abomination
yeah and like ultimate Hulk a little bit
can't believe the whole building runs
off this one dinky box got this whole
hacking thing down oh no the serers
there should be a backup Jarvis AI some
patience we got a Friday a Wadsworth an
Edith 1.0 BBC mystery just pick W bar
wner it
is oh give me wner hers a it's Christmas
the only difference between a hero and a
villain is good
PR it isn't about Penance no it's about
rebranding and that Hulk blood was going
to be my chance it's not a bad boy yeah
it really is perspective good pointy man
don't let him spook you happy that's
right ho ho Hogan I got your girl Friday
ho ho Hogan how do we not think of that
right there right and and My Girl Friday
has a girl Friday clever oh my goodness
the billionaire got Captain America
socks wow the Press lie these two really
do not get
[Music]
along light them up
fellas happy
now oh so give us some biggy
pudding
the confetti Arrow sugar
cookies what the hell is that I love how
much Sam Rockwell showed up for this he
really is in he's back his deliver is
great we need him back for Iron Man 4 I
think that's Happy
Hogan not so happy that's a whole Hogan
that
[Music]
is uh yikes look if we can reboot Jarvis
already on it Barrow one you said you
were counting on me that means
something like mom is like medieval
creature he's just spitting his
dialogue Hammer Hammer it's such a fun
mix between Hulk and ruffalo's portrayal
he's just like this loose mad man it's
so
funny he's like psychotic yeah he's
actually going nuts like
deranged
cool man Christmas Hulk
[Music]
movie
waa
W yo that was surprisingly cool oh
that's
great I love they reing the oil have
this Blood Splat effect that was really
cool that that was great that was
surprisingly awesome that was so metal
we get to see some Hulk oh man and it
took oil again like in dror
strange not going to be a Christmas
miracle oh Famous Last Words Hulk Hogan
there it is he said it called it
Sam oh we got a Hulk Buster soon get Sam
Rockwell as Iron Man I'm excited
Hulkbuster we need to gain control of
the suit now upload Jarvis but
German this is the worst internship
ever Hulkbuster is clever let's make it
quick I just need a little slice oh you
get a piece of
me
yes there's no way that Stark is paying
you enough to deal with the
hammer oh boy hey what are you
doing
nothing oh yeah best boss ever oh Darcy
really oh that means a lot coming from
well someone who's had just so many
bosses oh my life so funny just so many
bosses quick control out the lead that
actually worked little trick I picked up
in turning for the Culver University it
Department have you ever had an actual
paying job
nope
I really think I hope it's run herong so
bad all right we're up disengage I think
it is in the beginning men control now
machines control the fate of men that's
great are you calling me they say in
German
no what the hell is this program I love
the physical the physical gags I have
same here some movie time
Jujitsu
no it's fun rooting for the Hulk in the
scenario after
[Music]
Ultron Yes W Savage I miss
Hulk son of a nut cracker that monster
is eating my
[Music]
suit so sorry
yes I got a full Avenger shot oh God
Bruce a little help no guys got
[Laughter]
this where's Thor this is really fun so
this is genuinely fun this is this is a
good Christmas watch yeah this is a
really fun episode that's where we got
here no no no he's on the guest
list it's me happy that is the bad
[Laughter]
guy good
Landing oh the Sonic
[Music]
scream well someone's got to catch
him you saved me why it's Christmas
Hammer Goodwill towards men I'm sorry
about the party Tony I'm sure insurance
will cover most of are you kidding
you're the only insurance policy I'll
ever need a you do have a cure don't you
I mean I'm not stuck this way
right my head is security everybody how
about this
guy but I Heard a Voice say as the
heroes vanished from sight Merry
Christmas to
all guys oh I miss the
party to all a good night I like that
Thor was missing CU they always have the
Hulk Thor separate
thing they like laugh that that inside
nod oh that was
cute oh
man man man you know what's really cute
when you have people who back the
channel during holiday
season allowing you to pay people a
little bit extra because you got to work
during the
holidays so thanks to our sponsor
today thank you to Shopify for
sponsoring which is what we use for our
merch store and is our gamechanging
partner in e-commerce so whether you're
launching a passion project or scaling
to new heights Shopify is e-commerce
Powerhouse guiding you at every step
from creating your first online store to
opening physical locations Shopify makes
it seamless it's perfect whether you're
selling exclusive merch or unique
Collectibles thanks to their
all-encompassing platform for both
online and in store sales their checkout
system unmatched it's 36% more effective
at converting visitors into buyers than
other platforms and let's not forget
Shopify magic the AI tool that elevates
your business with minimal effort but
seriously reflecting on our journey
using Shopify for www. reation shop.com
it's been transformative the transition
smooth growth exponential thank you
again reject Nation from simplifying
sales to scaling our offerings Shopify
has been a Cornerstone of our success
and Shopify isn't just for us it Powers
10% of us e-commerce backing businesses
big and small in over 175 countries
there awardwinning support always there
to guide you so ready to join the
revolution sign up for Shopify at only a
dollar a month at shopify.com rejects
all lcase shopify.com rejects start your
Shopify success story now let's grow
together with Shopify team big thanks to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video a
real game changer I've been using for
years that's right years so whenever
they want to work with us it's an
instant yes you've likely heard about
expressvpn for online privacy and
security but there's more to it than
that however there was a very real
incident recently with Spectrum Shing
down my internet and contacting me due
to a suspecting hacking attempt and
funny enough I realized I hadn't
actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months
ago so I was paying the consequences
having faced a serious hacking issue on
YouTube a couple years ago that made
expressvpn my go-to for both security
and freedom I mean it and yes what
you've heard is true believe me this
channel knows you can use expressvpn to
watch movies and shows on Netflix that
are not available in your country this
means accessing a vast rate of content
of over 100 countries like a global
Cinema your fingertips it's super easy
open expressvpn switch locations refresh
the browser and there you have it
whether it's kramas on South Korean
Netflix Hulu BBC I player YouTube or
more expressvpn has you covered and it's
incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's
versatile too working on not just
computers but phones media consoles
Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows on anywhere
any screen protect and elevate your
internet experience so if you want to
get access to hundreds of new shows use
my link express expressvpn.com Rejects
and you can get an extra 3 months of
expressvpn for free that's
expressvpn.com reject so head to
expressvpn.com reex to learn more thank
you again all the Hawkeye toys being
Lefty
I that it was marked down and still
there all righty Ross Marquand was
Warner Herzog I love Ross that's great
that makes sense he did the he does the
German voices for you know he's the
German guy he's the German guy
apparently um yeah okay so you know how
last episode I was saying that I really
enjoyed the first two thirds but the
last third left me down so that was kind
of Lasting Impression and you like this
time I enjoy the second two thirs that's
what I wanted yeah this time it was like
okay the first third I'm enjoying
there's a little bit of a dip in the
second part of it for me I had I had a
bit of a dip but then once it just
started embracing like just whacka
dooodle do we're going to go all out
Bonkers crazy here and just uh embrace
the the once it really adjusted to okay
he's not just going to become the Hulk
like he's going to keep the voice he's
going to keep a personality and they
just start having fun with going a
little bit more maob and a little bit
more violent and wacky uh I started like
falling in love with it yeah it started
off like all right yeah this cool I get
they're doing the Die Hard thing this is
fun and then um then it was kind of like
whatever but then suddenly it was like
I'm really l I had this shift here I was
like so so as a as a whole for an
episode I think it's actually a really
solid Christmas special it feels like a
Christmas special episode and I'm so
happy Marvel has a Christmas special cuz
DC's been crushing it for so long and I
love watching like DC Christmas specials
Marvel hasn't really had one no I mean
they had the Guardians of the Galaxy one
sure but that was live action it's not
as like free spirited it's like it feels
like you know it's got some heaviness to
it it's got like this is like you throw
on and have a romp like I love the
Christmas special for guardians but
that's not something you watch with kids
like casually this you can just put on I
mean it's like it pays tribute to a lot
of Christmas movies like the obvious one
being die hard and then but they they
throw in references to like a Christmas
car there's a whole list I mean the
Christmas story that like
story Yeah Christmas Story and as as the
whole thing progresses what they started
really I think utilizing in terms of
their animation medium was really strong
visual gags yeah whether that be with
cool you know fight moment Savage Hulk
finally yeah we haven't had him like
that in so long it felt so good to have
a back in a long time but it was used in
a funny way that was also cool and I
like when you could do both yeah because
he's just embracing it but the way they
would cut around to certain things there
was like a lot of specific editing
choices a lot of specific great just V
again visual gags and even even them
cutting to The Avengers showing up and
they pay theage the ultra those outfits
which is such a comic thing to have them
in alternate outfits but they're also
not they're also going to find out
hoken and they don't realize it so they
think they're doing like the superh
heroic fight but they're not beating up
their friends it's really funny like it
got that that last third I loved I
absolutely loved it yeah uh so I'm a big
sucker for a Christmas movie as you guys
probably know and I'm a huge sucker for
mixing genres and this completely nailed
that thing that I love about I I talk
about it a lot with phase one and phase
two we like Heist movie Ant-Man like
everyone's talked about it at nauseum
but we haven't really had a fun
Christmas movie because how heavy Iron
Man 3 is I I love Iron Man 3 it's in my
top half of Marvel I think it is
underappreciated I think it's got bad PR
I think Iron Man 3 is exceptional but
it's not like a fun time it's it's good
at Christmas because of the other side
of Christmas it's heavy it's got trauma
this is just the joy of Christmas
there's a DC movie out this Christmas
called U Mery little Batman and I just
watched it yesterday and it is so what
you love about worth it oh dude it's so
much fun it is so like it's on Amazon
right yeah and it it is a romp it's just
like what you love about Christmas
movies it's that fun-spirited when
you're a kid and you just put on like
Grinch and you're just like this is just
Joy that's Mary little Batman and this
was that so I like my more adult mature
somber Christmas stuff but and mo most
of my favorite movies end up being
Christmas adjacent because I'm a huge
chain black fan but also uh like in
Bru's Christmas Kiss Kiss Bang Bang is
Christmas sheam black and like but I
want fun for the morning of and I love
that this gave me some of my favorite
characters in a Preposterous romp and it
used them in ways that feel like an
accurate representation of where the Age
of Ultron characters were when
everything wasn't broken because if you
look at the MCU as you get into phase
three everyone's pretty exhausted and
the world's [__] and then by the time
you get into phase four it's therapy we
haven't had them fun in a while it was
so cool to go back to Age of Ultron and
have like the playful Scarlet Johansson
played by Lake Bell to have like Tony
back before you know it's also
interesting to look at the casting be
like oh those characters that left the
MCU everybody else is their own voice um
like it was only like Bell andon I was
like all right well they're there but um
having the fun of phas 2 but mixed with
Christmas mixed with a genius pun of
Hulk Hogan there was so much in there
that I was just like Overjoyed to live
through yeah I think in terms of an
episode itself I this one I really got
this episode two felt like episode two
of what
if this felt like they knew this was a
they had a a Christmas special on their
hands yes and the way it ramps up I
think is really well done like it
escalates and it builds really well age
so even in that second act where I
thought like something pacing wasn't
really pacing wise it was more just
creative decision-making wise that was
sort of Dipping for me it it still
wouldn't have it any other way because
of how it actually ramped up to where we
got to I I appreciated the build like
like it's actually really well paced
when you think about it it starts off
I'm kind of just like I know you would
expect blessing
I don't know you would expect but then
as it gets to the finale again it's it's
like they're slowly pushing on that
acceleration button uh acceleration
pedal a little bit more as we're going
yeah I also like Sam Rocko is my
favorite character that has never come
back like Justin Hammer is the guy I've
been waiting for and I really hope he's
in armor Wars this was such a reminder
of like how great Sam Rockwell is
suggest he showed up man he just like he
had the most dialog by a large margin he
really played like a voice over
performance here like it was full and it
reminds you of like one the power of Sam
Rockwell but also as bad as Iron Man 2
is it's still the one with Justin Hammer
like that that's the thing that makes
Iron Man 2 so watchable is the Improv
nature of John favro teaming up with
Tony but also that Justin Hammer is a
delight every time he's on screen and
that was a big reason why this episode's
so fun yes it's got Die Hard references
yes it's got all these like hij Jinks
but Justin Hammer is literally dancing
through the episode I loved it uh and
then also like I'm not as big of a Die
Hard fan as L the weapon fan but it's so
formative to Christmas that I think they
handled the plot well because Avengers
Tower tying That Into You know uh yokei
Plaza what's the Y Yaki
Yaki I forget correct this yeah that's
all the comments now it's them being
like you idiots the greatest movie of
all time it is it's like Fox Studios
like right down the anyway uh yes that
place having that be the plot was genius
I was hoping
thisable yeah y shano bable
Tower sponsors that's our sponsor today
U but like this episode um I was hoping
we'd finally solve the mystery of who
bought Avengers Tower as teased and
Spider-Man we still don't know yeah I
was hoping what if would answer that
question I was hoping of all things what
if would give us a big narrative push
episode three of what if would tell us
Marvel's been planting seeds we're going
to find out celestials purpose we're
going to find out who bought Avengers
Tower yeah yeah this was really fun at
first at first I was kind of concerned
like oh man am I not going to love this
one yeah yeah but then again I miss
brutal Hulk that last third really
really did wonders rener came back to
get made fun of with the hkey yeah yeah
that was great uh I thought there was
really fun references throughout and a
lot of great homages both to The
Avengers universe and Christmas movie
simultaneously but again like I thought
they made a really smart choice on how
to handle Hulk Hogan here Hulk Hogan was
genius yeah I I my I really thought they
like cuz they what they in terms of like
a story that was building too with him
he's slowly morphing physically it
wasn't just he gets in injected it did
the unexpected with how to handle him
sure cuz not only does he not just morph
like you normally when you see Hulk
transformation you know even if it's
just hit with gammer is or whatever they
just turn into it Abomination just turns
into it actually except in the no he he
slowly turns right yeah but like this
was not not by body when you get that
full in yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like a
it's like a body horror experience for
that's was they made it like a body
horror comedy out out of him and I that
was the last thing I expected them to do
and the voice change and his jacqulyn H
face face is like and he's making jokes
when he's like Jaclyn hi about it and
you could feel John fa wrote like that's
when he was really having fun with the
role where you could see him in the
voice Booth like doing like mannerisms
with his mouth and everything hear it
for sure yeah could I really appreciate
how they kept him with a personality
instead of him just having be some like
monster like like they made him like a
deranged
weird it was really funny and the joke
at the end but he's like you can fix
this right ah my head is security
brushing off the actual problem such a
Tony Stark answer to and the look of
panic on an animated character's face
when it ejects itself why would it do
that it was so good yeah this episode
was a blast yeah that this was a really
fun episode I I was surprised uh so far
I mean it's going to be really hard to
top that first one it will I think this
was more fun honestly that's the point
this I mean that was this is the point
of but I think episode one is the best
made I think it's yeah oh absolutely
this this is like gen but sometime
especially with the comic book genre
using the word fun is often a way to
dismiss a bad
movie but this this was genuinely like
I'm having a great time I'm excited to
throw this on in rotation on Christmas
also I watched Grinch last night and the
Grinch is one of my favorites period
animation anything I love Dr Seuss uh
it's 27 minutes I didn't realize how
short Grinch was growing up
uh this is perfect because it's like the
same thing as like the the Rudolphs and
the Grinch and like those it's an
episode that feels like a movie The Ron
Howard one's like two and a half hours
you know Jim carre's not gonna not gonna
make that money for Less you go you
gotta earn that $100
million I'm Maring the Jim car one
tomorrow I'm excited there's playing at
the rooftop there's a theater in La I'm
not a big fan really seen it twice do
you like the cat and the hat Mike Myers
never seen it never seen it either let's
watch it that's the one let's me and you
team up to do a rewatch of a never
watched Mike Myers Cat in the Hat yeah I
I love Dr Seuss I just I've been scared
to watch that because I love Dr Seuss
I'm not a big fan of of yeah I know
everyone loves that Jim Carrey one
you're not a theator gell man that's Dr
I
think my real honest opinion oh you're
about to ruin Christmas I think Jim car
is really annoying in it oh okay I
thought you're gonna disrespect Dr Seuss
I'm okay with you I like almost
everything around that movie except Jim
Cary but Jim car's performance do you
like the Grinch character yeah yeah
okay the original animated movie the the
30 minute one have you seen the Scott
moer one that came out in like 2018 I
haven't seen the one with Benedict
Cumberbatch says it's Grinch maybe it's
like
CGI uh yeah Oh you mean uh yeah it's
like computer anime yeah yeah yeah I
haven't seen it's directed by Scott moer
Kevin Smith's buddy that's an oh no I
haven't seen it now the clerk's producer
like Kevin Smith let's do it in February
let's do it let's do it when it's
relevant let's do it Valentine's Day
let's hit that up for Arbor
Day yeah know I haven't seen it all
right well by next Christmas me we're
going to watch Grinch and Cat in the Hat
Greg and I teaming up you thought you
liked our equalizer reactions wait until
we watch The Cat in the Hat kids we
watch the family Kung F than anything
else we it's not as funny as a
tangent The Cat in the Hat to be fun I
like Dr Seuss I just haven't seen it all
righty guys what do you think about this
episode leave your thoughts down below
happy holidays to you subscribe leave a
like patron of the day Shout Out ho ho
ho
all right John pick your name Andrew
Hayes Andrew Hayes you know what I'm
going to get you for Christmas this year
s is delivering to you oh coming down
that gy he is a delivering first an
operating table hey you're going to wake
up strapped to an operating
table it's going to be there you're
going to think you're in some weird
Nightmare and you're in some sleep
paralysis thing that you just cannot get
out of like I need to wake up but ho ho
ho no you're on the naughty list you're
on the naughty list this
year Santa is going to uh surgically
remove your legs without anesthesia
because anesthesia is a sin for some
reason yeah he's a Christian Scientist
he doesn't believe in medication and
he's going to make sure your mouth is
just really taped shut so that way you
can't even scream man you can't even do
it but he's going to give you a new pair
of legs so you're taller Bute you're
going to be like what are those mythical
creatures with the Hooves the oh like uh
like Mr tness what is a Mr tness uh he's
got like goat legs goat legs on yeah
those guys fawn fawn yeah he's a fawn
he's turning you into a fawn and Santa's
going to turn you into a fawn so you're
going to you're wake you're going be
taller be like whoa I can see above the
table and I can like run yeah I can run
and then you take off your jeans to see
your new big thing and you're going to
be like oh my God Santa gave me Fawn
legs yeah and you're going to be like oh
no and that's the ironic tale is you are
now taller but you have fawns yeah so at
what cost did you achieve this height
for and and the ultimate mystery that we
cut away from to commercial break is
like did he leave your thing or did he
give you a fwn thing and which one is
bigger you know well that's what the
sequels were oh that's right yeah it's
Andrew trying to find love his own kind
so Andrew I hope this holiday season you
could learn to adjust to your new life
you could have been just a paraplegic
you could have but now you got Fawn
legs say you should have been a
paraplegic uh so really man you should
have been a paraplegic man you should
have just said no Santa pleas please
just no I don't need the PA legs man
keep my keep my stubs uh but really man
it's your call and I hope you have a
great Christmas with your family and
your hot mom and uh continue saving
people from getting their houses broken
in yes my fond man
[Music]
yeah